[Musique]
alors pas évident d'être intéressant en
parlant d'un sujet comme ça mais on va
essayer tout d'abord je vous présentais
ceci ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est c'est
la machine roulante la plus immense
jamais construit par l'humain cette
machine ses 225 mètres de long cette
machine
ses 96 mètres de haut cette machine ses
15000 tonnes 15 mille tonnes qui servent
à quoi
qui servent à récupérer du charbon dans
les mines de lignite
en allemagne la roue que vous voyez au
premier plan des 20 mètres de diamètre
elle comporte 20 godet chaque godet est
capable de récupérer 15 mètres cubes de
roche à chaque pelletée 15 mètres cubes
de roche c'est ce qui permet d'alimenter
trois foyers toute l'année en énergie en
électricité et en chauffage
c'est pour vous dire la démesure de
cette machine cette machine il y en a
plusieurs dans les mines de lignite en
allemagne notamment dans une qui
s'appelle hambach qui est la plus grande
mine à ciel ouvert qui exploite la
limite est donc le charbon en allemagne
cette machine elle démontre toute
l'étendue du génie humain
combien d'ingénieurs doit être fier
d'avoir participé à la création d'une
partie de cette machine à revoir soulevé
un problème avoir résolu un problème
elle montre aussi à quel point nous
n'avons pas de limite
alors si je vous parle de cette machine
c'est que cette machine je les vues de
près de très près même puisque l'année
dernière je suis allé là bloqué et que
demain j'y retourne pourquoi pourquoi un
est un ancien élève ingénieur un
ingénieur comme moi se retrouve un jour
à bloquer la machine comme ça qui
pourtant représente ce qu'est capable de
faire le gène humain est donc l'un
génial et donc ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est mon cheminement
comment j'en suis arrivée là
comment j'en suis arrivée là et pourquoi
alors pourquoi vous le connaissez tous
pourquoi laisser le dérèglement
climatique
vous en avez tous entendu parler nous
sommes accros aux énergies fossiles
nous émettons énormément de gaz à effet
de serre je rappelle juste en trois
chiffres
2200 milliards de tonnes de co2 émises
ça c'est ce qui a été fait depuis en
ciel depuis un siècle un peu près 40
milliards de tonnes de co2 par an c'est
ce que nous émettons dans l'atmosphère
est tout ce que nous avons fait déjà a
eu pour effet d'augmenter de 1 degré
dérèglement climatique le réchauffement
climatique 1° c'est l'état de la
situation actuelle mais les
scientifiques vous l'avez très
certainement entendu parler dans les
médias et autres nous donne des
projections vers où est ce qu'on veut et
nous disent que si on veut rester dans
quelque chose d'acceptable c'est à dire
un monde que l'on connaît un monde dans
lequel on sait que l'humain peut vivre
de manière souhaitable il faut pas qu'on
dépasse 2 degrés et même ce serait
rudement intelligent quand ce limite un
réchauffement de 1.52 alors forcément
j'ai entendu ces chiffres comme vous et
puis je me suis intéressé à la situation
j'ai eu la chance dans mon parcours
d'élèves ingénieurs riche en engagement
associatif de croiser une association
qui s'appelle avenir climatique
cette association c'est la première qui
a réussi à me mettre vraiment le doigt
sur le problème à m'expliquer l'aspect
systémique de ce problème que c'était
pas simplement une question de
dérèglement climatique que ce n'était
pas simplement une question de il fera
plus chaud mais c'était vraiment en fait
notre système tel que nous l'avons conçu
et que le système terre finalement c'est
un système qui est très bien réglée mais
que l'on perturbe un petit peu
aujourd'hui on perturbe par nos modes de
fonctionnement et ces perturbations et
bell ont des conséquences en sortie ses
conséquences mais on l'a vu c'est le le
fait que le monde se réchauffe mais pas
simplement c'est aussi le fait qu' une
dérive la dérégulation des systèmes
pluviométrique vous avez des zones qui
étaient aujourd'hui déjà inondé qu'ils
le sont encore plus vous avez très
certainement entendu parler récemment de
divers divers problèmes liés à l'eau le
pendant c'est qu'il ya d'autres zones
qui se dessèchent aujourd'hui vous avez
le rhin qui est au plus bas de son
niveau historique il ya plus 70
centimètres d'eau sur certains ponts à
cologne notamment
vous avez donc des répercussions qui
sont importantes fonte de la banquise
incendies géants etc etc
mais ça ce sont des conséquences
environnementales il n'y a pas que ça il
ya aussi des répercussions sur l'humain
et des répercussions ce sont des
familles ont ce sont des conflits ce
sont des guerres bref la société humaine
est en train de rentrer dans une
situation où on provoque de
l'immigration on provoque de la violence
où on provoque quelque chose qui est
plus difficile d'accepter comme
condition de vie donc j'ai creusé toutes
ces thématiques avec cette association
je me suis engagé avec elle et puis j'ai
commencé à informer informer les
étudiants
sur ces sujets là alors on a développé
tout un tas de programmes dont un qu'on
appelle l'académie où on forme une
centaine de jeunes sur une année à
comprendre ces enjeux à être en capacité
de les répliquer c'est bien mais très
vite on se rend compte que finalement on
est limité dans notre action que il ya
finalement quelque chose qui empêche le
changement c'est pas que l'information
s'est pas qu'une question d'information
on peut informer les gens mais c'est pas
suffisant alors très vite on se rend
compte que mais il existe aussi tout un
tas d'alternative et que finalement si
on veut changer de système puisqu'il
s'agit bien de ça il faut faire émerger
un nouveau système et ce nouveau système
en fait il existe déjà
il existe déjà parce que pour toutes les
problématiques on a trouvé des solutions
aujourd'hui on est capable de se
déplacer on connaît des moyens de se
déplacer qu'ils n'utilisent pas de
pétrole le premier d'entre eux c'est le
vélo on sait que on peut tendre vers une
alimentation plus saine plus local -
carnets et en plus c'est meilleur pour
la santé et ça permet de faire des
économies
il existe des fournisseurs d'énergie
alternatives comme enercoop qui
permettent d'avoir une électricité local
100 % renouvelable et avec un lien
direct avec le producteur
vous avez des personnes qui vont tendre
vers une mode de vie zéro déchet en
arrêtant de consommer de gaspiller du
plastique qui ont fabriqué leurs
produits ménagers ou même vous avez
aussi un pouvoir d'action sur la manière
dont vous allez investir votre argent
est ce que vous le mettez dans une
banque qui va placer cet argent pour
développer l'énergie fossile ou est-ce
qu'au contraire vous voulez investissez
dans une épargne solidaire dans quelque
chose qui recrée du lien localement vous
pouvez évidemment agir localement
vous pouvez vous impliquer dans les
politiques locales et vous pouvez faire
en sorte à votre échelle d'être un
vecteur de changement des choses voilà
ça c'est bien mais ça c'est pas
suffisant
et ça les scientifiques ne leur disent
régulièrement vous avez très
certainement entendu parler depuis deux
semaines maintenant d'un nouveau rapport
qui a été publié par le giec est logique
c'est le groupe intergouvernemental
gouvernant mentale d'experts sur
l'évolution du climat
et c'est un rapport spécial qui nous dit
bah qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement restées sous 1,5 degré et
donc on apprend notamment
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un 25 degrés
par rapport à 2 degrés et dans le monde
dans laquelle on va vivre alors je vais
le prendre en trois exemples le premier
c'est la fonte de la banquise la
banquise c'est ce qui recouvre l'océan
arctique au nord de la planète d'une
offre d'une couche de glace
cette couche pourrait fondre on pourrait
se retrouver en été avec plus du tout de
glace à ce niveau là si on se limite à
un réchauffement des cinq degrés ça
arrivera une fois tous les cent ans
si on se limite à un réchauffement de
deux degrés ça arrivera une fois tous
les dix ans si on se limite à un
réchauffement de 3 degrés ce sera tous
les ans donc nous connaîtrons vous
connaîtrez un monde dans lequel
probablement il n'y aura plus de glace
dans l'antarctique dans l'article un
deuxième point sa disparition des récifs
coralliens alors que les récifs
coralliens vous c'est des belles images
qui nous donne envie de partir loin pour
pourvoir tous et tous ces récifs cécile
qu'aurélien aujourd'hui ils sont en voie
de disparition
et c'est très inquiétant parce que 50%
de la population marine des animaux
marins se reproduise grâce aux récifs
coralliens avec 1 25 degrés de
réchauffement climatique on perd 70 %
des récifs coralliens avec deux degrés
de réchauffement climatique on perd 100
% des récifs coralliens 99% vont dire
les scientifiques bref on a tout un tas
de chiffres comme ça sur extinction la
biodiversité c'est pareil c'est deux
fois pire à 2 degrés que 5 degrés est
donc on est dans une situation d'urgence
les situations d'urgence climatique et
ces mêmes scientifiques nous disent que
finalement la fenêtre de tir
elle est assez ténue parce qu'en deux
ans on doit changer complètement le
comportement nos comportements le
comportement de nos sociétés avant 2020
2020 cédant 2 en 2020 la plupart d'entre
vous vous ne serait même pas rentrer
dans la vie active
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire si
faire massifier les alternatives
actuelle n'est pas suffisant eh ben
la solution c'est de bloquer le système
actuel sept saulx de résister de
s'opposer d'arrêter de coopérer avec ce
qui aujourd'hui est coupable du
dérèglement climatique et donc c'est
comme ça que j'en suis arrivé moi en
tant que ingénieur en ayant creusé ces
sujets on est regardé ce que pouvait
faire dans ma vie
on est rendu compte que ce n'était pas
suffisant à rejoindre des groupes comme
ça comme vous pouvez voir ici alors vous
avez entendu parler de la coop 21
j'imagine la conférence des parties qui
a donné lieu à l'accord de paris là où
tous les chefs d'état se sont félicités
de dire nous allons réussir à rester
sous les deux degrés qui quand il a
fallu définir qui sait qu'ils allaient
faire le premier pas à tout le monde
s'est regardé les pieds puis personne
n'a rien fait et bien pendant cette coop
21 vous avez une société civile qui
s'organisait qui a dit hé ben non on va
créer un grand mouvement de masse un
mouvement qui est debout et qui est
déterminé pour le
climat et on va les opposer lorsqu'il ya
des problèmes lorsqu'il ya des actions
qui vont à l'encontre de ce que nous on
pense comme étant compatible avec
l'accord de paris alors ce mouvement il
a fallu le faire avec un certain nombre
d'éléments qui permettent à tout le
monde de se retrouver dedans donc l'une
des caractéristiques principales c'est
que on a fait de ce mouvement un
mouvement 100% mongueurs la non violence
c'est quelque chose qui est fondamental
si on veut pouvoir faire adhérer la
majorité des gens et comme on considère
que c'est un problème qui touche
l'ensemble de la population l'ensemble
des classes il y a besoin que tout le
monde puisse se retrouver dans ce
mouvement là la deuxième
le deuxième volet fondamental c'est la
légitimité
si on le fait c'est pas parce qu'on veut
faire changer les choses
sur la base d'un discours c'est
simplement parce que la science les
connaissances scientifiques actuelles
nous disent que c'est fondamental de le
faire et l'ensemble des politiques
l'ensemble des chefs d'états de l'accord
de paris se sont mis d'accord sur le
fait qu'il fallait respecter cet
engagement des deux degrés alors
concrètement comment comment est ce
qu'on fait je vous racontais yeux l'une
des premières actions dans lesquelles je
me suis impliqué c'est la campagne qu'on
appelle les faucheurs de chaise
je sais pas si vous avez entendu parler
des faucheurs de chaise c'est parti
d'une idée suite suite un fait
d'actualité
on apprenait que la hsbc était coupable
d'évasion fiscale et qu'un certain
nombre de milliards ne rentrait pas dans
les caisses de l'état mais partie dans
des paradis fiscaux
alors on s'est dit bon on va rentrer
dans une banque dans une hsbc pour le
coup et on va piquer des chaises puis on
les rendra quand ils ont rendu les
milliards donc on a fait une première
fois et puis on s'est dit c'est marrant
comme comme moyen d'action donc on va le
refaire et en 2015 en préparant la coop
21 eh ben on a on appliquer un peu plus
de 196 chaise dans dans des grandes
banques les grandes banques qui sont
pratiques pratiquement tout responsable
d'évasion fiscale c'est chez elles nous
ont permis d'organiser le procès des 196
chaise pendant la coop 21 ou des
représentants des différentes
organisations autochtones du monde
entier ont fait leur propre sommet en
marge du sommet de la coop 21% va dire
construire un monde qui soit beaucoup
plus enviable pour tous alors je vous ai
dit que ont piqué des chaises mais là
vous voyez l'image que c'était un autre
type d'action
parce que parfois on est venu avec nos
propres chaise dans l'est
c'est un autre type d'action s'est dit
pas ce que l'on va faire c'est qu'on va
montrer tout ce que pourrait financer
l'argent de l'évasion fiscale s'il ne
partait pas dans les paradis fiscaux
mais s'il restait en france à soutenir
les services publics et donc c'est comme
ça que on a fait une cantine scolaire
dans une banque qu'on a fait bailly si
vous voyez une école dans une banque
qu'on a simulé des crèches qu'on a fait
une émission de radio qu'on a fait des
cons à simuler des hôpitaux etc etc bref
on s'est bien amusé avec ses chaises
avec ses banques puis un jour il a fallu
les rendre ces chaises parce que ces
encombrants quand même 196 donc ce qu'on
s'est dit c'est que bah on allait les
ramener au palais de justice puis on
allait les ramener le jour de
l'ouverture du procès de jérôme cahuzac
ce ministre qui est pas tout à fait
compris les règles du jeu voilà donc on
est venu douce avec une petite chaise
sur la tête
on s'est dirigé vers le palais de
justice et puis s'en remettre avant le
palais du justice sur le sur le pont au
change a été bloqué bloqués par les
forces de l'ordre qui trouvaient que
notre plaisanterie elle avait assez duré
et donc ils nous ont demandé de poser
ses chaises et puis on s'exécute et qui
on a laissé les choses sur ce point et
puis on est parti quand on s'est bien
amusés à voir que les forces de l'ordre
plus d'une cinquantaine de crs s'étaient
employés à surveiller sous la pluie des
chaises vides sur un pont est ce que
c'est un symbole du système dans lequel
on vit je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
nous ça vous a bien fait marrer donc
voilà le type d'action que l'on mène
dans le cadre de cette campagne
ce que l'on voulait c'était faire parler
dans la presse pour parler au grand
public de l'évasion fiscale que les gens
comprennent que finalement quand on dit
il n'ya pas assez d'argent pour tel
sujet et en particulier pour la
transition énergétique
en fait c'est simplement une position
politique mais que cet argent on
pourrait la voir si on le souhaitait il
pourrait se débloquer niveau européen et
pourrait se débloquer au niveau français
il suffit simplement d'avoir une
position ferme sur sur ce sujet et sur
le sujet de l'évasion fiscale et puis
coup de pot alors qu'on avait fini nos
petits jeux avec nos chaises la bnp
paribas a décidé de nous faire un procès
très grande idée de la part de la bnp
paribas qui nous a permis d'organiser
une grande manifestation est d'avoir
trois mille personnes qui étaient au
procès de john palais le faucheur de
chaises qui a été arrêté coupable
on ne sait pas trop quoi même le
procureur a parlé d'emport de chaises et
donc il a été relaxé
mais en tout cas nous a permis
d'organiser procès de l'évasion fiscale
dans un vrai procès avec des avocats
avec eva joly qui témoignait à faire
avec eva joly comme avocat avec des
témoins et ce qui nous a permis de ne
pas être ce sujet mais comme la bnp
paribas n'a pas voulu s'arrêter là et
merci à elle elle a organisé en 2009 de
demander enfin on a eu un deuxième
procès puis un troisième procès ce qui
nous a permis de changer d'échelle et de
se dire ok et bien maintenant on va
toucher là où ça fait vraiment mal est
en fait le problème qu'ont avec la bnp
paribas aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
finance c'est qu'elle finançait parce
que la bnp paribas est un bon élève
maintenant c'est qu'elle finançait la le
un certain nombre de projets
climaticides c'est à dire des pipes
lines qui transporte 2 qui transporte du
pétrole
c'est à dire des nouveaux projets de
forage offshore des projets de mines de
charbon etc et donc à force de contester
à force d'aller récupérer des chaises
dans la banque à force de la pointer du
doigt eh ben la bnp paribas a décidé de
se désengager des énergies fossiles et
donc c'était une victoire pour tous ceux
qui sont mobilisés contre la bnp paribas
alors aujourd'hui du coup il reste une
grande banque en france qui ne s'est pas
mobilisé encore il ne s'est pas engagé à
désinvestir des énergies fossiles
c'est la société générale voilà et donc
du coup bah qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui suite à la sortie de ce
rapport du giec c'est que on démontre on
rend visible tout ce qui pour nous sont
les coupables du dérèglement climatique
en apposant des mains rouges sur les
sièges de ces grandes entreprises ou
forcément vous avez la société générale
j'en ai parlé parce qu'en tant que
banque
elle a un pouvoir direct très souvent
quand vous parlez de changements
climatiques beaucoup de gens vous disent
oui mais en france on aimait que 2% des
émissions s'est pas vraiment nous les
responsables cas responsable c'est les
chinois à l'étape et sur les chinois
parce que chinois ça allait mais 30% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vas-y
mais comment est ce qu'ils peuvent le
faire déjà et pourquoi ils le font ils
le font pour nous pour qu'on puisse
avoir nos smartphones dans notre poche
et puis le font parce qu'on investit
aussi chez eux alors j'ai pris l'exemple
de la chine mais j'aurais pu prendre
l'exemple de n'importe quel pays et donc
on a un pouvoir l'action en tant que
citoyen français c'est de dire à nos
grandes sociétés qui finance à nos
grandes banques d'investissement arrêter
d'investir arrêté de promouvoir ces
projets qui n'ont de toute façon pas
tenir
en plus en ensemble leurs rangs un sacré
service parce que finalement investir
dans ces projets vu l'état de nos
connaissances scientifiques
en fait c'est un investissement qui ne
sera pas rentable pour elle à long terme
voilà donc on s'oppose à des à des
organisations comme la société générale
alors évidemment notre petit chouchou
c'est totale parce que total total ils
ont toujours la bonne idée de
communiquer au bon endroit au bon moment
total le jour où on sort le rapport du
giec sur les 1,5 degré pour dire qu'il
faudrait quand même vraiment arrêter les
bêtises et nous annonce tout fièrement
qui vont ouvrir deux champs de pétrole
en algérie total aujourd'hui ils
essayent de se positionner pour être la
première compagnie pétrolière allait
explorer du pétrole au large de
l'amazonie dans un nouveau récif qui
vient d'être découvert simplement avec
une diversité inouïe mais total tant
qu'il ya du pétrole
ils vont l'amener on aime bien les
taquiner total épiler le troisième
acteur bas ce sont les mines de charbon
forcément le charbon c'est 45 % de la
production d'électricité dans le monde
en france on est relativement épargnée 1
on a fermé nos mines il ya un certain
temps mais chez nos voisins directs en
allemagne il va c'est toujours
d'actualité
et aujourd'hui encore un électron sur
deux qui est produit en allemagne
il provient de mines de charbon et les
plus dégueulasses d'entre elles ces all
in its c'est un charbon qui est on va
dire très faible très très pauvre d'un
point de vue énergétique et qui
aujourd'hui des responsables du
dérèglement climatique pour une partie
assez signifie qu'en significative
donc voilà comment d'élèves ingénieurs
qui rêvait de travailler sur une plate
forme pétrolière qui finalement a été
touché par ce discours qui a rejoint un
certain nombre d'organisations qui lui
ont permis de comprendre ce problème on
se retrouve allait partir avec des
milliers de personnes pour bloquer ne
serait ce qu'une journée une mine de
charbon et je peux vous assurer que
quand on est là bas on a vraiment
l'impression d'être à la bonne place au
bon moment on a vraiment l'impression de
faire partie de ceux qui sont en train
d'écrire l'histoire pour faire en sorte
que celle ci ne s'arrêtent pas douze
mille ans après qu'elle ait commencé
donc si j'avais un conseil à vous donner
aujourd'hui ce serait celui de m votre
intelligence au service de l'humanité
non plus au service du capital c'est
d'agir c'est de réagir c'est de vous
opposer quand quelque chose ne convient
pas à ce qui est votre idéal mais
surtout
c'est de prendre du plaisir à ce que
vous faites est de n'avoir rien à
regretter
quand vous devrez expliquer à vos
enfants le monde dans lequel ils vivent
merci
[Applaudissements]